ich mache mir da keine illusionen dem
klassischen hfd wähler ist das alles
egal was wir gerade erzählt haben
hauptsache wut in die wahlurne kotzen
und feierabend wenn wir da überhaupt
eine reguläre wahl hinkriegen noch geht
ja die angst um vor russischen hackern
natürlich er natürlich wer weiß wer weiß
wie die unsere ergebnis manipulieren am
sonntag plötzlich sind die grünen bei 10
prozent
aber gut ich will es auch nicht völlig
von etlichen natürlich gibt es russische
hacker sie haben bei der us-wahl und in
frankreich mitgemischt
aber wer sind diese leute kriminelle
staatlich bezahlte agenten alles falsch
hacker sind freie menschen sie sind wir
künstler
wenn ein künstler sich morgens gut fühlt
dann malt ihr den ganzen tag das gleiche
gilt für hacker natürlich stehe und
zwölf künstler ich stehe um 12 auf fühle
mich gut gegangen und hätte die
bundestagswahl künstler so irgendwelche
russen haben ja schon mal sie erinnern
sich unseren bundestag gehackt aber
offenbar nichts spannendes gefunden was
mir auch irgendwie zu denken wie es ist
so blöd wenn ich so blöd dass ich damals
in der computer ag nicht richtig
aufgepasst haben in zeiten in denen
jeder den geheimdiensten ausgeliefert zu
sein scheint strahlen hacker ein
gewisses sex appeal aus
aber aber technisch ist schon lustig es
ist schon lustig wie sich jetzt alle
wegen der bösen russen ins hemd machen
greifen unsere rechner an
da sind wir voll die datenschützer aber
dass unser eigener staat weil überall
videokameras mit
gesichtserkennungssoftware aufhängen
möchte das interessiert hier keinen
hering unser innenminister ist total
begeistert von der technik
wenn sie in berlin durch die straßen
gehen und sehen den er im restaurant ein
der ihn bekannt vorkommt dann können sie
dass ihr smartphone dahin halten und
dann sagt das natürlich ein hertha-sieg
juni ja wo dafür brauchst deine software
da hat er recht ja klar brauchst du
dafür eine software ohne software denkst
du doch sollten graue haare
ist das wirklich george clooney oder
doch birgit schrowange wann immer er
jetzt soweit beispiel ist doch nur ein
beispiel gesichtserkennungssoftware
vorbei
wie gesagt wir wollen es nicht
verniedlichen natürlich könnte es noch
hacker angriffe geben bis sonntag ein
29-jähriger it experte aus hessen hat
gerade war sie aus langeweile mal eben
die software pc war gehackt das ist ein
programm das in vielen bundesländern zum
erfassen und auswerten unserer stimmen
eingesetzt wird
einfach mal so geknackt war das sind
schwierig was jeder kennen sollte ist
das problem mit zu schwachen passwörtern
wir haben hier auf dem webserver
passwörtern identifizieren können die
lauteten test also wirklich sechs fächer
treppe verbindet den test nach der
sendung konto passwort aber wie peinlich
ist das denn test